[Music]
and cut the crap news cut it out right
sounds a good [ __ ] sitcom yeah I just
saw scissors going into that was weird
that's squishy very - it was scissors in
like a like a solid poop coming out but
solid what are you guys talking about so
this is coming out of a pothole and you
cut it but you both saw blue coming out
of a bun and scissors cutting it cut the
crap you said it I think you really
emphasized the crap I see it it's a
visual person
I saw this in sitcom you saw dude right
thank you for anything I saw [ __ ] Dave
Coulier being like yeah I got it out
what that means about us and our
personalities I don't like it you
smarter probably yeah oh yeah cuz you
see poop yeah we see people's [ __ ]
okay
geo we read between the lines submitted
by chitty-chitty-bang-bang I like that
that is an old movie or some [ __ ]
achieving bang it's a reference everyone
understands but maybe no one's seen know
there's a movie called Chitty Chitty
Bang Bang it's a car yeah it's an
old-timey car were like before they had
roofs over their cars you know oh yeah
yeah yeah we're they big squeeze the
horn is like pow and the car like has a
personality it takes some places and
then they start singing about it cuz
they're like they love their card cuz
it's like got a personality that's
actually pretty good another you said
looks like Knight Rider before night
right I just remember dates mature be
like Jinjin bein mayne geegee of a mayor
well I think that was the theme song
yeah Chitty Chitty Bang Bang we love you
but no did it be beta that's the only
reference I have for me yeah so didn't
remember the rest but you know he thank
God a reddit user shared a story about
his family's poop night and it's
disgusting Wow we weren't really close
damn it like when they're constipated
and they [ __ ] dig in their butthole
to likely [ __ ] [ __ ] come out maybe it's
a knife shaped like a poop like it's uh
I hope so what do you mean no I think
logical reason all like why do you need
to cut your poop with a knife like when
the family has a knife that cuts the
poop
I said you when you're constipated I
don't know anybody that sticks a knife
no I know I'm trying to get in her
little arms go in a warm bath tub is
that what you do even experiences I
watched you and Steve do okay weird
really let came out what we openly say
we're weird Oh like we openly don't say
it well honey we're not weird stop it
we're not I know I'm not weird for sure
but I just looking all right so this guy
all right girl
oh yeah it's okay so this reddit user he
posted entire story on this confession
reddit the title says I was 22 years old
when I learned that not every family has
a poop knife now the story here said to
my family poops big maybe its genetic
maybe it's our diet they all compare how
do they know maybe it called your toilet
really like you where you have to tell
me when your [ __ ] [ __ ] is out of the
water okay I feel like it clogged the
toilet sometimes it's it's like I don't
know like this big me so proud well it
comes from the hole and it's coming all
the way out of the water okay it's
coming out of the water line I'm like
down it's a big what's relaxing there's
other things you can brag about I know
he could brag about how like smart and I
wasn't bragging I was sherry and I'm
like you should go check out wait wait
there's a difference between sharing
like oh hey I heard that like on the
news today they're gonna have the sale
in our city that's not personal
that's sharing bragging is like oh ho ho
you should have [ __ ] with the ho ho hos
okay that was a giggle you should have
seen in my [ __ ] like didn't eat like was
coming out of the water you want to see
that took a picture it's exactly the
South Park episode oh no like Randy
always takes pictures of his [ __ ] and
shares it with his guy friends and they
like they're like oh mine's bigger this
time I got how I Met Your Mother like
it's on the news that he took the
biggest [ __ ] huh it weighs like three
Katie Couric's like that's how they
measure [ __ ] and then it takes a life on
its own and I can't kill it and it's you
know it's self worth but that is scary
so you do what these pictures you
circulate them you posted it one time
birth started on Instagram people used
to use snapchat for guys would do
snapchat snapchat well that has a little
bit more decency than posting it on
Instagram where it doesn't disappear
because I knew I could relate to people
out there that late that ones there's
definitely a market for that yeah he
continues maybe its genetic maybe it's
our diet but everyone births giant logs
of crap if anyone has laid a mega poop
you know that sometimes it won't flush
it lays across the hole in the bottom of
the bowl and the vortex creamy water
merely gives it a spin as it mocks you
growing that that's pretty funny guys
gotta be a cute writer it can't just say
you know you gotta yeah I got to be a
[ __ ] writer about it hmm hating your
life no no I just gotta know what he's
doing I gave it a ebook link yeah
growing up this was a comment enough
occurrence that our family had a poop
knife it was an old rusty kitchen knife
that hung on a nail in the laundry room
only to be used for that purpose
it was normal you gotta shake the
[ __ ] so it goes in through the
hallway and have someone call out hey
can you get me the poop knife I thought
it was a standard kit you have your
plunger how do you how do you hand it
off I think you just tossed it hey you
ready grab the handle if i'm antonea
food knife okay and you're taking it
from me fast forward to 22 it's been a
day or two between poops and I'm over at
my friend's house my friend was a local
dealer and always had guests over
because you can't buy a weed without
sitting on your ass and sampling it for
an hour I excused myself and lay a
gigantic turd I look down and see that
it's a sideways one so I cracked the
door and call out for my friend he
arrives and I asked him for his poop
knife my what your poop knife I say I
need to use it please my back is a poo
tonight obviously he has one maybe he
calls it by a more delicate name a fecal
cleaver a dumb divider a guano glazed
[ __ ] writer dude yeah I explain what
it is I want and why I want it
he starts giggling then laughing then
lots of people start laughing it turns
out the music stopped and everyone heard
my please through the door it also turns
out that none of
them had poop knives it was just my
[ __ ] up family with their fucked-up
bowels [ __ ] my life I told this to my
wife's last night who-who was amused and
horrified at the same time waiting you
never talked to his wife about this
it starts to come apart oh go ahead go
ahead I'm sorry it turns out that she
did not know what a poop knife was and
had been using the old rusty knife
hanging in the utility no this story's
[ __ ] okay basic utility night no at
least she didn't cook with it but use it
to open Amazon boxes she will be getting
her own utility knife now Eddie
common question why was this not in the
bathroom instead of the laundry room
answer we only had one poop knife and
the laundry room was central to all
three bathrooms I have no idea why we
didn't have three pooping I just hang
one in each bathroom yeah all I know he
never talked to his wife about the poop
knife before but okay if it's so common
for every so do you think it's one of
those clickbait stories or no I think
that reddit seven out of ten stories
that are on reddit are like creative
writing exercises basically like people
trying like [ __ ] launch to writing
careers and [ __ ] a little interesting
especially the ones that write the ghost
stories trying to believe it though just
a little bit because what if they both
live because he's 22 what if they both
live at the parents house like why would
he ever need to have that conversation I
recently took a [ __ ] where it was in an
establishment I had a couple of floaters
and they had those water-saving ones and
I flushed it and it wouldn't go down and
I flush it again and I'm just like it's
not flooding it's just not going
according to plan
no there's like three or four Nuggets
still just [ __ ] floating around and
I'm like [ __ ] dude so I put the plunger
down and I try to get it to like flush
because you know when you plunger it it
goes yeah and the whole thing goes it
never the the reservoir of water never
completely went down so there was always
a pool just [ __ ] turgut's why those
was mocking you water and I stood like
eight times and I'm like because used to
flush more like so it doesn't say why it
doesn't you ever grab his done treasure
represent nah next question I just left
and indoors
and I was like [ __ ] sucks to be you and
just throw it away why are you even used
a [ __ ] tissue at that point well the
papers so [ __ ] pissed
hey Bart sometimes you gotta use a beach
towel and I'm talking good job send me
that picture again the only relatable
experience I've had with this is with
the rice cooker I thought everyone had a
rice cooker only Asians out rice cookers
yeah like so wait how do I know it's
crazy Casey Casey cooks it Casey cooks
rice yeah how do you do that without
putting too much water or I don't know
you measured the same exact way Steve
does it the pie what do I do before I
moved in with you you just made rice
with a pot yeah of course see I make it
like an old Japanese lady no you don't
know these lady would have a rice cooker
yeah no we've been having rice cookers
since like the 1200 yeah they have big
ones too they have the like legit sized
ones they like use the whole bagger no
but like how far back do you think you
guys have had right since I was a kid
going on my grandparents house um
[ __ ] antique gas rice cooker with no
options yet they do it over fire now you
have all these options writing their
buttons my grandparents one is just
click like a toaster - you just cook it
once like a toaster yeah just one just
one button thing with the black handle
and it's all aluminum looking yeah and
it just it just cook it looks like an
appliance from the 50s I thought that
was why people [ __ ] no that's funny no
not one single white friend you know
like it's like I'll take our book and
rice cookers is what Ben did different
white told me is what I was gonna say no
no no I thought that you know you make
it with your with the pot and water like
it's that's the old way well cuz I
thought that that would be the old way
of doing it like Oh like a pot the
authentic way it would be to do it with
the pot old-school
like you're taking a shortcut like using
a microwave or whatever if you use a
rice cooker I don't know we just made so
much rice how do you measure it so much
rice how much water you need to 1 cup of
rice put in 2 cups of water that's what
I learned
like you can do on the rice cuz that's
what I do we all use our fingers you
come at the distance you like this line
case you taught me that
yeah yeah but what have you got a big
old fingers didn't have a porridge yeah
I just picked through the run trineas
[ __ ] I just eyeball it
[Music]
you